[Music]
and thank you for watching the honest
trailer commentary for
tenant
hey everybody welcome to the australian
counter it's for
tenant tenant um we're not live today
uh it's a uh it's pretty much the day
before christmas break i guess for us um
so we're just
this is our gift to you because uh we
could have just skipped this because the
honest trailer isn't even done yet
at this point in time but we're gonna
talk about it anyways you're gonna see
the very first rough cut of an honest
trailer and we're going to talk about it
yay so this could be somewhat different
from the one you end up seeing
um we'll see how much more work we put
into it over christmas break
we are also going to start at the end
and then we'll start at the beginning
and then everybody will meet in the
middle
in a pincer move obviously exactly we're
going to find out that we're friends at
the end of this
oh oh yeah just like tennis uh
that's joe that's lawn or vice versa
um and uh yeah we uh we
we won't be able to respond to questions
and comments from viewers like you
because it hasn't happened yet unless
you've inverted yourself
uh but we will and we also don't have
outtakes because they'll be in the
trailer themselves so
whatever whatever also i guarantee we
have more questions than you guys
i could just fill this whole show with
just questions we've got questions
um overall reactions to tenet i think
that uh
look lon did you see it in theaters
no i saw it for the first time just the
other day
i mean i feel like the disclaimer needs
to be
that we all watch tenet you know i
watched it twice
uh but and i don't think anybody
uh here has watched it more than once
otherwise
like we didn't have it twice i've
watched it yeah
but no and normally i would watch
when i get an honest trailer's
assignment you know i i roll up my
sleeves ready to hate something and just
watch it on my laptop
but i i gave this the nolan in my living
room treatment and did watch it on my tv
in are
i smoked a pipe and i i did my tea up
real nice
and uh yeah i don't think i've ever
watched a movie for honest trailers just
like on my television
yeah i watched it in uh in a toga
uh on my thinking lounge um as all nolan
films
should be consumed
sipping mulled wine uh that said
look this is probably
um close to my least favorite chris
nolan movie at this point in time but it
also
increased my respect for christopher
nolan in a
in a way because he is clearly not
um he's clearly making the types of
films he wants and he is doubling down
on i think everything that you either
love or hate about him as we say in the
trailer and like
this is what he this is the film that
he's interested in making and these are
the kind of things he's interested in
exploring on film
he's not listening to his critics he's
not gonna make a rom-com or like
you know that's that would be the
extreme of it but he's not going to
moderate himself
he's going to make christopher nolan
movies and this is
a christopher nolan movie to the extreme
um
not my cup of tea uh but i do think that
um weirdly i came out of it and be like
all right so that's
that's the kind of filmmaker you are and
that's kind of filmmaker you want to be
more power to you i i hope other people
are are are more into it and continue to
to ride this crazy ride with them what
did you guys think
um i think that at every stage
conceptually
it must have really seemed like action
sequences that are both forward and
backward
would look really cool and like in dr
strange that stuff looks pretty cool
and it just doesn't look cool like i
like i think everything
else that i was sort of not crazy about
with the movie i would be willing to
forgive
if like the core thing which is these
big action sequences that they're
conducting like
half in forward time and half in reverse
time
just like felt more visceral and cool
and like
there's they're trying really hard and
it's very conceptually interesting
but there's nothing in this movie that
hits as hard as like a vin diesel flying
headbutt in a fast and furious movie
like
there's i kept waiting for it to get
thrilling or exciting
and it's it's just not it's too hard to
like parse what's going on for it to
feel exciting
so it's yeah it's one thing i ask you to
it's one thing to ask you to
puzzle your way through uh plot details
like i'm used to that i can
i can stomach that and and i don't mind
like reading up about it afterwards and
going back through and saying oh
but when you're puzzling your way
through the action it's just not what
actions for action is something visceral
like there's something in your body that
can feel
you know cause and effect like this pool
ball hits the other pool ball and it
makes it fly that way and when it's
backwards you're just
and forwards at the same time you're
just kind of having to think your way
through
what's happening yeah in the action
scenes actually especially
like it can't be a puzzle box because
action has to be an action sequence has
to be
clear with the beginning middle end not
a beginning a middle another middle and
middle and middle and end and in the
beginning uh
because yeah like you're sort of saying
we then we can't like track it and then
we can't
we can go wow this is interesting but i
can also do that with like
a windows media player uh music
visualizer
um which is less expensive than i think
this
you know you know it's christopher
nolan's not a bad filmmaker i
it's weird because um i was
really kind of bored this whole movie
like it it never like
grabbed me it never picked up
there was no change in in pace to me
between
talking about brooks brothers suits to
stealing a plane and driving it into a
building like nothing ever
picked up it was all just kinda
um which was which we but then on the
other hand like i keep thinking about
the stupid movie
not in like a whoa way but i just i do
keep thinking about like i keep going
back and and
and think about the action sequences you
know it missed an emotional hook for me
memento
was also a kind of a gimmicky big idea
movie
but emotionally i bought into the panic
that this man must be feeling
that he loses his memory all the time
and it had the mystery to dig into and
dark knight
you know had the um heath ledger's
performance as this visceral thing you
could hook into
and yeah inception it hung on him trying
to get back to
see his his children uh same with
interstellar in a way
it was like uh they had some emotional
core that you could hang your head on
but this guy
he's just so removed from everything
going on
it's also like all of those films in the
past that nolan does they're all like
plays on very conventional genres so
he's making this very like
heady weird kind of convoluted tough to
follow at times
take on something we're familiar with
like inception is just a heist movie
it's just a heist movie like in a dream
and like memento's just a detective
noir kind of thing but like with a dude
who can't remember anything and he's got
to like write everything down you know
like they're all kind of like that but
then you get to
this one and it's like i it's kind of a
spy thriller but to work as a spy movie
you've got to be able to follow all the
moves and like by halfway through
it just becomes too hard to follow all
the moves and i feel like you gotta pick
one or the other like i mean it's like a
bond but it's like an
early bond when like they thought that
you were really there for the plot
like uh right like a thunderball era
and that's kind of my point like if this
was trying to be bond it's not fun like
if it's gonna be like heady and serious
and grim
then like it needs to be sort of like
about something it just felt like it
kind of couldn't pick its lane like
there is like a bond movie in here that
would be fun but like
brauna's not playing it like a bondville
and he's playing it very
dour and serious and like yeah there's
you go to exotic locations but then you
sit in one area the whole time like you
don't go see
the cool parts of the exotic locations i
think there's really something
to that lawn what you're saying because
it's like it needs one or the other
if it's gonna be kind of i'm trying
i'm trying to i'm not trying to call it
like a basic movie
but like because it's very heady but i
don't think it's as clever as it thinks
it is and so if it's gonna be sort of
just like a run-of-the-mill
because the moment you see him fight
himself at the beginning or you see the
lady jump off the boat i've seen a time
travel movie before
and i went oh that's her you know uh but
if it's not going to be
so complex i've never seen anything like
it then it needs to have the
the charm and swagger um you know
yeah that's kind of what i'm saying like
if the action really worked i would have
been sold or if it was just like a
really fun
exotic fast-paced adventure that was
kind of fun i would have been sold
but it's like none of those things it's
like this really grim
dour movie that's all about these ideas
and then i kind of also couldn't follow
the ideas
well i guess we're just too stupid to
appreciate chris nolan and with that
uh let's play and again i will repeat
this is
version one i don't think that there's
any music uh i think that there might be
all the alternate jokes will still be in
the trailer so
um let's see this beta version of uh
by these three beta males of what the
tenet honest trailer looks come watch us
work something out at the open mic that
we wrote on a napkin
totally uncensored too so there will be
nudity
the full front pal sorry guys it's in
loan's contract
from warner bros and their former bro
yeah it's
uh sort of not how you treat filmmakers
and stars
comes a film about technology i mean
that's interesting to speculate like
who's gonna make chris nolan's next
movie because it doesn't sound like it's
going to be warner brothers
i desperately want it to be a24 with an
a24 size budget
yeah sure i mean he's done it before
with like momento and following
and um 824 could probably insomnia
yeah i i cause i actually really not to
be like i like nolan back in the day but
i don't think insomnia gets enough love
it's a pretty good i mean like it's
happening a lot yeah
it doesn't have nolan concepts per se
but it's it's a good movie so i'd love
to see him do something like that again
yeah i mean it is really cool that he
gets to be like one of the
three auteurs we're allowed to have at
any one time
in in cinema but like and i don't want
him to become a hired gun but it would
be cool to see him direct somebody
else's
story i think he could i i did when they
were talking about him maybe doing a
bond i guess this was what he ended up
doing sort of instead of that but like
i mean it would be interesting but it
would also depend on is he willing to
like
loosen up a little bit and have a little
more fun or would you get a very like
stern bond film where bond goes on some
sort of a time
jumping adventure well as we learn at
the end of this trailer you know he
loves tokyo drift so much
like yeah tapped into his inner tokyo
drift
yes please and shaw and uh and michael
kane
go back in time baby it's all there yeah
christopher nolan just being like cut
now lil bow wow
on this next take to the camera i really
want you to sell me the idea that these
babes are going to get into your hulk
car with you
[Laughter]
oh man uh yeah i want to see him
directing
was it lucas black is that his name is
lucas black that's yeah
yeah international he's the perfect
actor he doesn't emote
at all
he's my muse just come on when you're
facing a really difficult
moment i want you to think to yourself
how would sean boswell
handle this the protagonist from tokyo
drive
i've just felt it's so interesting to to
you know leave
uh uh you know my fine dining experience
go to a waffle house with with him you
know he's
less of a protagonist to more of a
protagonist and it's just so easy to
roll up my sleeves and revisit my polo
days with the boys at the club
okay keep going filmmakers and
stars comes a film about technology that
reverses the flow of time
that nolan wishes was real so he could
have released the movie four months
earlier
tenet experience what happens when a
filmmaker goes so far up his own butt
that everything gets it's inverted two
antagonists
one inverted a machine plain burden she
shot when an inverted round
you are inverted the world does not blue
team uh inverted thought you were
inverted can you stabilize the inverse
radiation by inverting the patient that
would take twice the number of memento
plot
dongs to properly explain that's
basically the end of the movie
but basically some people and objects
are moving backwards in time
the people moving forwards in time can
interact with them and everyone's
fighting to control a big mass staff
that blasts the past
did you still get lost don't worry so
did the cast
sometimes the logic needed to catch up
to what i believe he would feel
in the moment even if i can't all the
way explain what it was you know
it's getting it's it's gotta be really
hard for
the actors in this movie to play like
the emotions of a scene from from moment
to moment when
yeah it's so hard to follow who they are
at that point in time
yes and no but they're also like they
have the guy
like right there behind the camera who
could just tell them like we
i i would almost like to have had that
where if you could just like
pause the movies i could be like chris
what would kenneth branagh's experience
of this scene be like all right long
because like that's what
they have access to like they could just
ask him so like they're kind of
like well that would be totally
understand he could just be there like
well you just got to this cave but you
haven't been here the whole time you
know like
that would be the ultimate charity
raffle you win
the ultimate prize for this charity
raffle is chris nolan comes to your home
and watches socially distance and you
can pause pause tenet at any point and
ask him what's happening this would be a
great like
alexa feature like he should just record
this like the whole movie just answering
questions the whole time
so you'd be like hey uh alexa like well
what what the heck just happened to be
like
well oh right here's what's happening i
don't know why he's irish when i do it
i also want to give spencer props for uh
uh creating the
the 80s toy commercial pitch for tennant
the toy because i can definitely see a
kid with a cool skateboard and like a
bowl cut
being like it's a math staff that bless
the pass
that's definitely yeah so the algorithm
i mean in the
in the uh grand pantheon of doomsday
devices this one's
a stretch man it's it's a math equation
uh but each piece of the equation
instead of writing it down on a piece of
paper and tearing that into little
pieces it's
like a wizard's step wonky like in the
future they don't have
flash drives anymore so we've had to put
together this thing
i mean my question not to fall down the
rabbit hole into of like
uh nitpicky questions but if it's uh the
scientist found out the equation for
destroying reversing the entire flow of
time and didn't want anybody to find it
she and she did kill herself why did she
like go through the
trouble of like encoding it into these
things and spreading it all around into
horcruxes all over the world like
why didn't she just kill herself you
mean like never
leave it for anybody to find never leave
it for anyone right because scientists
are ego
egotistical maniac spencer um uh
she had to do it she absolutely she just
she just had to like the riddler
yeah super powers is leading batman to
his crimes
she really wanted someone to find all
the pieces of the algorithm and put it
together so that she could give them the
jade key to open the oasis
are you saying that tenet is about
gunters i'm saying
basically tenant is like ready player
one
but for like math nerds like not for
regular nerd like right blair was for
regular nerds
this is physics nerds ready player three
is gonna be nothing but
nolan references and it's kinda i'm
going to
you sent me that thing where where ready
player 3 is going to be about early
2000's
internet culture 2000 is like meme
internet so it's just
i can has cheeseburger references i knew
it was a neon cat so i was able to pass
the rainbow bridge
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not even a question of getting
everything or even anything i think even
when me and john david were just
shooting the last scene
i think i was still asking him
fundamental questions about saying
i think my last question was saying like
am i alive
or dead critics have taken nolan to task
for his overbaked plots
underdeveloped characters and all white
heroes
well he's addressed one of those things
denzel washington stars as the
protagonist
a mysterious secret um protagonist who
uh
look he's a protagonist okay that's all
you're gonna get he's joined by neil
a fellow time i mean he's he's the hero
and uh he he starts off as a uh
cia the you know operator who will do
whatever it takes to get the job done
and he ends the film as a cia operator
will do whatever it takes to get the job
done
yeah it's i think the he really no one
really wrote himself into a corner with
this one because he obviously had the
bit
spoiler alert everybody he obviously had
the bit that in mind for a while that
in the end we're gonna find out that
john david washington actually
runs the whole organization and this is
just his
first experience of it but like in
more time he's going to rise to the top
and i feel like that ended up like
mate forcing him into like a lot of
corners where he just couldn't establish
the character better
because then he'd be creating like weird
paradoxy things
you're saying he inverted his own
writing process kind of because it does
feel like he purposely didn't want us to
like get to know this guy which does
kind of hurt your involvement
in this way like my here's one question
just as an example we don't have to
answer it today
uh why would he need to test his own
medal
as we see at the beginning of the movie
where he's like we got to make sure you
would be willing to take that
pill and kill yourself instead of give
up your but like it's you
you don't need to test yourself you're
already you
am i the right guy for this job well you
have the job so
huh the right guy for it and it's like
more
like every time you add something to his
character you add
another one of those you know it hurts
my brain but i i can only think that
um noted tokyo drift and fast and
furious fan chris nolan
um is also a connoisseur of the triple x
franchise that does the exact same thing
before you join the triplex program
right you do have yes you also i mean
that's a that's kind of an old
uh uh i feel like a lot of the stuff in
the first hour
he's purposely playing on like 60s and
70s british
spy movies and it's like really kind of
like dry and a lot of like people having
like high level meetings where they talk
about like
who you know a lot of names you don't
know and you're trying to like catch up
like that you know tinker taylor soldier
spy kind of vibe
and like i thought that was kind of cool
but uh it does not stay like that for
very long
yeah i guess my i don't know i guess my
assumption was like
that part wasn't him yet
maybe like the cia was aware of this
problem
tested his medal to investigate it and
then that's when his
like timeline starts um
i guess i mean even neil was there it's
so confusing because even
there was even
we talked about this also is like the
the suicide pill that they
do in in scene one does not go off in
act three when they have another fake
suicide pill right
which is like basic chekhov's gun stuff
chris yeah you think that anyways it's
it's honestly too complicated if you
haven't seen the movie
you probably you should watch the movie
um but it's too complicated to even
explain to you right now what we're
annoyed by if you haven't
it would take too long yeah let's just
keep watching
well this is kind of what i was talking
about like at the beginning where um
i'm frustrated that like i can keep
having
these like non-stop loopy conversations
about the about a movie that like
i was not at all invested in like that's
so irritating to me
like it's just the conversation like
there isn't anything else it's not an
adventure it's not funny there's no real
like
there's nothing to grab you and like
it's not really about much of anything
it's just this platform for like
but it's just untangling the mechanics
of it it is like
untying a really complicated knot like
at least that money gets you off
yeah like at least the the what's going
on of
donnie darko like made me like cry when
i heard the
madworld song when i was 22. so i could
at least
have an emotional attachment around
round and round talking about it but
yeah this i was just like well yeah
there's an emotional court of dianadarco
about you know the self-sacrifice of a
annoying teenager
um and then with uh with his other
movies that he gave you more of
something that like even if you didn't
understand what was going on you
emotionally understood what the
character was going through and i
don't think that's there in this one or
like the the bigger
cause that the movie was about and this
one there's like a real offhand mention
of
of global warming i think is what is why
the past is trying to attack us
uh but that's that's it yeah the future
very complicated it's like the future
they want to reverse time because they
messed up the planet so badly well we
all did but
like the planet's so messed up that they
won reverse time but you can't just
reverse time because we're already here
in the past
and the clash we win because we're
moving forward
so they have to obliterate time and then
they can reverse time and like
fill in the gap which is now a void
with new time and i guess if you even if
you do like
if that is what he was interested in and
that's like the the
moral quandary he was wrestling with in
this movie it's such a grim
conclusion is that like well the
president is going to absolutely fight
for its right to continue
to uh destroy and consume the planet and
we're gonna win and it's everything's
gonna die right yeah
everything that happens happens like you
can't
it's not about changing anything like
that's
that's just preserving our own asses
right it's just like well but that won't
happen until later
like all right genius save the future
great job okay let's keep going
a fellow time cop who's the bill to
protagonist ted
let me get after some stuff you're gonna
love it dudes
you guys are gonna go back in time yeah
you are going to have a most
excellent adventure hey you never did
tell me who recruited you neil
you did who are you guys were you dude
no way max who continues the grand nolan
tradition
of largely mute children you only see
the hair of cat
a woman so tall she could drive a car
from the back seat
michael caine has himself sure why not
goodbye sir michael
and sator a vodka swirling arms dealer
who's an adidas tracksuit away from
checking off every evil russian
stereotype
you lecture me about radiation andrei
setor
digging plutonium from the rubble of my
city as a teenager
well that's not the most over-the-top
accident i've ever seen so i guess he
earned his paycheck
paid that man his money pushed through
physics yeah i don't know that's just
funny like that guy was
like he said like he was almost a bond
villain and i guess he had the the
fitbit that ends the world which is kind
of a
villain touch i i feel like that's a
touch that would have made me appreciate
this movie a lot more if like
instead of just a yacht and him being
like a russian stereotype it was like an
aqua layer
and he was like a bond villain type
character i'd be like okay
now i get it we're doing a nolan take on
like a 70s spy movie
yeah you do open up the door of being
able to send and presumably they've been
sending him
objects from the future that like he'd
have some sort of futuristic
tech or something at his disposal or
something cool that we haven't seen
before
but i was honestly uh i was honestly
expecting
like all roads lead to chernobyl like
that's
just with his weird backstory and with
all the radiation talk and what kind and
how much
i honestly thought the big uh uh time
crank and the mass staff and you know
all that was uh
gonna they were gonna throw down in
chernobyl that's what i was kind of
excited they basically did it was just
like a
chair nobody never heard about like the
i thought there's a cool concept and i'm
sure it's
real it's a great value soviet the
soviet secret
cities i think that is true yeah i'm
pretty sure that is based on a real
thing
yeah yeah that is neat
that's i mean the thing is like as much
as we are dumping on it right now like
there's always interesting ideas in
christopher nolan movies i mean i think
that's kind of a given
and this one is not different from that
like it's a cool twist on this sort of a
premise that i've never seen before
and so like yeah credit where it's due
he's coming up with cool interesting
ideas
i just feel like i don't know like it it
the
the city's folding over themselves thing
and inception looks really cool
and the the guys running backwards
shooting at each other
it doesn't look as cool like i think on
some level it really comes down to that
yeah yeah it just feels like like we're
like he's written
like uh a a 600 page hard sci-fi novel
and we're just dropped into page
245 to 265 and like without a
without a life raft and it's just like
if you're if you care and you're really
into it you can do the work and go piece
together everything but just as a
first and even second time movie going
experience it's just like
it's it's just my initial take
and like i pitched it as a joke and it
was only funny to me because i'm
currently watching the crown uh so very
funny and timely to me but it did
feel like it just felt like prince
philip dryly describing this movie to
olivia coleman
like that's what watching it felt like
and then a man goes through a device and
then he's moving backwards and then
olivia coleman goes oh my
it just just it was like listening to
someone describe their dream
i don't know it was wrong yeah okay keep
going
pay that man his money push through this
extremely dense and intricate way
of telling an unsatisfying hollow spy
story that feels like the movie
adaptation of a crossword puzzle
because it kinda is and when you strip
away the mind-bending sci-fi concept and
parse through the hard-to-hear dialogue
what do you know about opera terminal
from their private place and managed to
stay awake through all of the meetings
it's just a backdrop for rich people
doing time crimes to each other
like a rube goldberg machine that ends
with you getting kicked in the balls
it's your head hurt yeah
yes thrill as nolan rediscovers the
backwards action thingy from that spike
jones video
and the backwards talking thing from
that missy elliott song
of filming huge sequences in reverse
that in theory
sound like they reinvent the genre but
just looks like they chose the rehearsal
takes of them practicing the
choreography
and more of just a frustrating chore to
make sense of like someone inverted your
controls on gta
yeah this is me watching lieutenant
i think i get it no no no it's again
yeah just so we'll pause i think we've
touched on it but it is just the
um just to reiterate it's like the uh
the
feeling of watching the action sequences
is is
i mean maybe maybe your mileage may vary
because i saw a lot of people say like
the action this movie blew my mind and
maybe if you're watching this
in a theater or on a in a drive-in or
whatever but it just
it always looked like just an effect it
looked like a special effect i know that
sounds stupid but it's like
action needs to trick you into like
feeling real and feeling like you're in
it and this to me was
even though it's all in camera and super
impressive and technically
difficult to pull off it was as
disengaging to me as like the big cgi
armies at the end of a marvel movie
because my brain's just like that's not
real
it is like a lot of people and you know
in in my old age as i mellow
you know like what you like it's cool
like i totally had a hey do you like
pogs moment with
uh with a buddy of mine after i saw it
uh named for
which when i was uh in middle school a
guy ran up to me uh
uh with all the enthusiasm in the world
was like hey man do you like pogs and
had what was clearly a big bag of pogs
and i was like
no and he was like me neither cool
i was like oh i just saw tennant my
buddy was just like holy [ __ ]
you know whoa and this and that and i
was like i hated it
but uh yeah you're right it's it's like
technically challenging i'm sure but
like so is an ok
go video um wow
that was brutal
there's just right there's like this
disconnect like when you're thinking so
much about trying to figure out what's
happening you're not
in the moment just enjoying it for the
action for the spectacle
and i think that was where it sort of
broke down like i was just i couldn't
get out of the
like mode of weight but okay so those
guys are going like where are they going
where
okay where are they going like all these
pincer moves and after a while it's just
like
but i'm not following your i mean they
give you the instructions in the movie
which is like don't try to puzzle it out
like just feel it
johnson gives you what seems like a very
important briefing about where
everybody's going
and i'm trying to follow the briefing
but then we get out under the field
and there was that line they're saying
lines like lon what was it the most
nolan
lineup oh i'll see if i can find it i
think i have it in my notes still
um i only didn't put it in the script
because it was like you could barely
understand it even in the movie because
it was delivered like through a
crackling walkie-talkie yeah
the material is not in the case get the
other sections of the algorithm to the
hypocenter
it sounds like it's on like
interdimensional cable like like sure
okay yeah we need another gen michael
vincent in the quadrant
all right keep going
so suit up once again just not in that
off the rack poor person kind of way
brooks brothers won't cut it for what
may not be
no one at his best but it definitely is
no one at his most
that exaggerates everything you either
love or hate about his films
and if you're a nolan worshiper who
wants to rewatch something three times
before it makes sense
more power to you i just hope you know
you also have to pretend to love tokyo
drift too
what do you like about fast and furious
i'm sort of original recipe i mean the
fastest first robcon original
um but i i've got a very soft spot for
tokyo drift actually
story yeah pause good i mean of course
you would because that's the one that's
most
focused on street racing yeah he doesn't
like
that other uh nonsense um he likes it
focused on just the drifting
yeah just no none of the heists none of
the you know international espionage
just the drift then so
did you make the point we might have to
add this in a pickup or something where
it's like of course he loves that one it
messed up the chronology yeah right
he likes the one that was like oh no you
thought that this was just the third one
in the sequentially but no no no no this
is happening in the future
why do they have ipods then don't worry
about that listen
feel it they're inverted they're
inverted ipods yeah they have inverted
ipods from the past
it's hard like but yeah like you've
really got to watch it it's sort of a
trick in the
trick of the eye but bow wow is actually
getting out of that elevator
yeah weird with those babes all right so
that that might be in the honest trailer
by the time
you people see it uh all right keep
going
starring marty mcspy
let's just put the protagonist here for
now then come up with something better
later
good time pats to the future tinker time
lord soldier spy
time bandits in soviet russia time
reverses you
murders on the disorient express what if
vladimir putin
looked like harvey weinstein femme
fatale
my wife elizabeth wild beth
burly ives moody dench and how nolan
writes a character
there's more talk nothing that might
reveal who we are or what we do
mission invertible backwards to the
future
a man a plan a canal panama
whoa
yeah i love that uh that's that's a
pretty crazy uh palindrome
i i saw that in the script and i've been
like
i'm not gonna say anything about not
getting this joke because i should
reference i should read it backwards man
i don't want to feel stupid uh but now
that i see it's like oh it's a pound or
mine
yeah a man a plan a canal
okay i only have one word for you guys
pan i made a planet canal panama
oh yeah we didn't we we definitely
didn't really get into the hands and
like how anyone i just kept thinking
because it's
david brent does this yeah yeah it's
it's not the most
uncommon hand gesture and especially
it's kind of like a professorly thing so
you got to figure
some some like scholar has been like the
tenets of
national socialism but say what you get
so here's your backwards
at least
yeah they gotta add the like uh steeple
here's the people um all right keep
going
the inverted people a man
a plan a canal panama
whoa you know if i were inverted i'd
just poop in front of my enemy so they'd
have to watch as materializes on the
floor then shoots up into my butt cheeks
that'd be awesome i mean think about it
you'd walk in you see a see a poop
forming on the floor
some guy rolls in i do i do like the
idea that
much like the inverted bullet like you
only catch it if you hold
your hand over it like you dropped it
yeah like otherwise it doesn't know that
you dropped it
uh that you would have to like kind of
squat over the poop so it knows that it
can't you just have to do it on instinct
to be like i'm feeling particularly
empty and relieved right now i better
drop my pants
yeah you'd have to like you'd have to
you well you only that's only there if
you just pooped
and i'm also proud of us because i think
danielle timed it i think it was because
uh
this was a nice instance where we
watched it and then we all did like a
writer's room together
and i think danielle timed it and it was
what like four minutes before we
talked about what poop would be like
that'd get very far in no
i mean that was that was during my watch
i was thinking
what if you poop while you were in the
machine that inverts you guys what
happens then
yeah i don't think the turn think turn
style things make any sense either but
i don't know well they should have think
about that
just to be more british yeah you know
but uh it's um
radiation um
thank you guys uh if we haven't turned
off uh every uh
nolan fan at this point or if you are a
nolan fan screaming at us
while you're screaming uh like and
subscribe um hit the bell and you can
get uh
uh videos and we are genuinely sorry
that this couldn't be live because we're
all on vacation uh or we would be
handling your uh comments and questions
right now and i'm sure that there are
some very intelligent points and
rebuttals being made to what we've said
but can't see them too bad i have to go
back in time and figure that out
uh we also have some new videos i
imagine they're good
on this channel right now i don't have
what they are in the script but i'm sure
they're lovely
so click on those um and uh
yeah so i there's no outtakes there's no
questions
um uh i i hope you're happy that we've
done this
at all but uh but we will be back live
um
you know in january i imagine uh uh we
do have another special honest trailer
to end the year
um it's our hint would be uh
well what would our hint be uh it's
it's very current it's different from
everything we've tried before and it's
something very current
um but it's something that i'm excited
to try and i hope you all like that
because uh hey who knows maybe we'll do
it again
yeah um hopefully not hopefully we don't
have to but
yeah right uh maybe we could do it every
week who knows
uh with that said uh thank you lon thank
you joe
thank you everybody watching and
everybody involved it's been a year
hasn't it poo boy um but uh no one i'd
rather do it with again and uh
let's do just that when we're back in a
couple weeks
right here on australia's commentary vic
[Music]
invert
you